الاستثمار الامريكي مودرن ستانلي من ثلاثه
مخاطر تمويليه قال انها قد تضرب الاقتصاد
المصري بشده ابرزها احتمال خفض تصنيف مصر
الائتمانيين للمره الثانيه هذا العام كان
ذاك خبر حلقتنا لنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات
الى اي حد يعكس تحذير بنك الاستثمار
الامريكي الشهير الحاله الاقتصاديه في مصر
وكيف سينعكس تحذيره على نظره المستثمرين
الخارجيين كذلك ما امكانيه اقدام القاهره
على تعديل سعر الجنيه من جديد
وما مدى نجاعه الاجراءات التي اتخذتها
الحكومه المصريه للتعامل مع تحدياتها
الاقتصاديه
هذا التحذير متوقع وتقليل التصنيف
الائتماني لمصر متوقع وصدور تقارير سلبيه
عن حاله الاقتصاد المصري سواء حاليا او
مستقبلا متوقع في ظل عدم وجود مراجعه مع
صندوق النقد الدولي او عدم وضوح الرؤيه
بشان الاتفاق مع صندوق النقد الدولي سوف
تتوالى التقارير السلبيه على الاقتصاد
المصري
يعني المؤشرات السلبيه والتقارير التي
يعني تحذر بشده وخرجت من عده مراكز ابحاث
وبنوك ومؤسسات دوليه بان الاقتصاد المصري
يسير من شيء الى اسوا ان يصل خلال
الجمهوريه الجديده يعني عشر سنوات منذ
2013 يوليو 2023 سعر صرف الجنيه على
الدولار من 6 جنيه 35 قرش الى قرابه
الاربعين جنيه هذا امر خطير ان يزداد
معدله الفقر ويزداد معدلاته التضخم اخر
تقرير لبلوم بيرج الذي يقول ان مرسل
في العالم يزداد فيها اسعار الغذاء خلال
اقل من عام باكثر من 66% ويحذر البروفيسور
زي ستيف هانكي من جونز هوب بان التضخم في
مصر تجاوز 110% على مقياس قام به في جامعه
الشهيره فنحن امام مشكله حقيقيه محاوله
الاشقاء سواء كانوا افرادا او شركات خاصه
لمساعده الاقتصاد المصري كما قالت يعني
مديره صندوق النقد الدولي فنحن كمان يضع
ماء في وعاء مسطوب فيما لو فعلا خفض
التصريف الائتماني للمره الثانيه هذا
العام ما الذي تتوقع ان يحدث كلفه
الاقتراض سيحكم المستثمرين الدوليين سواء
كانوا في الاموال الساخنه او من ياتي لكي
يقوم استثمارات مباشره سيزداد وضع
الاقتصاد المصري قتامه
اعتقد انه لولا شهاده دولاريه كان من
المقرر ان يتم تخفيض قيمه الجنيه بنسبه
تتراوح ما بين عشرين الى 30% بمنتصف اغسطس
القادم يعني كنا نتحدث عن دولار يساوي ما
بين 45 الى 48 جنيه بعد موضوع الشهادات
الدولاريه انا اعتقد ان التخفيض سوف يكون
اقل حده ربما يبلغ الجنيه من 35 الى 38
جنيه صحيح ان التبعات سوف تكون غليظه على
المواطن المصري وعلى الاقتصاد المصري لكن
يعني فرق من 48 الى 38 اعتقد ان المساله
سوف تكون اقل قسوه ولو انها سوف تظل قاسيه
العمله كما تفضل يعني ضيف الكريم دكتور
عبد النبي من القاهره الى قرابه الاربعين
من 38 ل 40 مع على بدايه سبتمبر على
الاكثر يعني
[موسيقى]
الخيارات الموجوده امام الحكومه المصريه
الان هو خيار وحيد اكتشفير الاعتذار عن
المشروعات الغير مدروسه وبيع هذه
المشروعات ما يعني ما هو السبب الرئيسي
الذي يجعل مصر تقوم ببناء العلمين الجديده
والعاصمه الجديده والمونوريل والقطار
الكهربائي هذه المشروعات استنفذت يعني
عشرات بل مئات المليارات من الدولارات اهم
شيء على الاطلاق دمج الاقتصاد العسكري
داخل المصنع العامه للدوله ووضع الفوائد
التي لدى المؤسسه العسكريه تحت امره
الموازنه العامه للدوله مما يؤدي الى
انخفاض العجوزات فوائد اموال تنعكس في
ايجابا على المواطن المصري وتخفض من اسعار
السلع وتقلل من الاعباء الشديده التي
تتحملها للمواطن المصري الامر ينبغي نوع
من المكاشفه والمصارقه والاعتذار حتى
يكتذب ثقه ثقه المصريين في الخارج ثقه
رجال الاعمال وثقت الشركاء يعني الاقليين
المطلوب ان يتم توفير التمويل وهذا يعني
امر هين للافراج عن الواردات الموجوده
وخاصه مستلزمات الانتاج والمواد الخام وما
في حكمهم من اجل ان تعود لصناعه والزراعه
الى العمل يعني هناك بعض المصانع التي
اغلقت لعدم توافر المواد الخام او عدم
توافر قطع الغيار نتيجه الاجراءات التي تم
اتخاذها لتقييد الواردات هذه امور يمكن
بالتاكيد حلها وحلها بسهوله يعني مصر
بتمتلك احتياطي نقدي في حدود 34 مليار
دولار وهو اعلى كثيرا من الاحتياطي النجدي
النقدي العالمي المطلوب تستطيع مصر ان
تستخدم جزء من هذا الاحتياطي في حدود من 5
الى 10 مليار دولار للافراغ عن كل
الواردات الموجوده في الموالي المقدمه
اهميه الاحتياط النقدي ان لم يستخدم في
مثل هذه الظروف